to start I want to share with you guys
something about my hometown of Norwalk
Ohio now as this video stated I'm from
Norwalk which is extremely small town
about 15,000 people and really in
Norwalk you can do something fun you go
to Walmart or drive half-an-hour sling
more interesting and for Norwalk I've
lived there for my entire life I'm
senior at the local public high school
and you know it's something to wear I
really enjoy my small town and I'm just
a normal kid
you know I lead the big clubs I
volunteer at my church and back in
November of 2018
I made a small reddit post asking for
advice on an issue that I was
encountering that I needed some
clarification on and this issue as was
stated this instruction was something of
a nation's and how I was not immunized
against various diseases including polio
and measles as well as influenza HPV
hepatitis and the standard vaccines
someone my age would receive now this
question I asked was simple and pretty
strange because you know I wanted to get
vaccinated that's kind of weird but you
know what happened and then this turned
into a public story because I wanted to
get vaccinated so that was kind of
strange and then it blew up more and I
was doing interviews and talking to more
people and again I'm a normal kid I'm
not a scientist I don't lead a
non-profit I am again pretty pretty
casual person I'm wearing a hoodie and
because of this this question and this
this story because I'm gonna get
vaccinated in this interesting situation
I was in I saw that I quickly was in
this public setting of an extremely
important controversy and discussion
taking place now I saw that the stories
and headlines were pretty accurate the
most part you know after defying an anti
vaccine expressed his why he got
vaccinated pretty accurate pretty true
and as stated I testified in front of
Senate committee so there they said this
teen who self acts and has ripped his
mom's anti bags placed in front of
Congress okay I didn't really do that
but I said that that's fine and certain
certain news outlets took a little
further God knows how I'm still alive
danger 18 finally gets vaccinated and
attacks his anti evacs parents so I did
not attack my parents that's not
accurate at all and you know really my
story was more about controversy it was
about how my mom was bad and I was good
and I was ripping her a new one not true
not what was happening I never was rude
towards my mother and even in public
settings where I expressed how her
beliefs were misinformed I said that she
was a loving mother and that's important
understand because a lot of people I
think in a scientific community that
understand why vaccines are so important
can really be confused why someone would
not vaccinate really it's we can compare
it to someone not taking their child to
the ER that's a very dangerous situation
to be in and it shows some lack of
empathy towards your children in some
regards and really I can understand that
I can but my mom she was misinformed and
misled by sources that convinced her
that if she was a loving parent she
wouldn't vaccinate now when I
encountered this and I talked to my mom
it you know didn't obviously go well at
first because I was wanting to do
something that she thought would either
cause autism or maim me for the rest of
my life and I said I wanted to do this
didn't really fly generally go well but
the thing that I found interesting was
that when I had started to get into the
circumstance do these interviews there's
one question I proposed wasn't a
positive one what in the world if I got
myself into that's what I asked
constantly because again I am NOT an
expert I am a normal kid and now I'm
talking to CNN and Fox News about a
scientific discussion that really should
I really be facilitated
should I be commenting on and a lot of
people question that and for good reason
but I never claimed things that I didn't
understand I talked about my personal
experiences and really even at the
Senate hearing I just talked about how
misinformation is dangerous
my mom got allowed her beliefs from
social media from Facebook and from
organizations that were allowing their
platforms to push lies that were very
dangerous now
I also saw that as I was doing this and
I was doing this as respectfully as I
could and as accurately as I could I was
doing a lot of criticism a lot of very
angry people I know as I went when I was
in in DC for that testimony I gave I
remember I was looking around the office
building and three ladies got in an
elevator with me and said I'm the reason
that children are being maimed and
murdered and I am basically Hitler so
that was fun and so really in for most
circumstances for most teenagers and
most people when they get criticized
this leads to doubt and that doubt least
of questioning and that questioning
leads to quitting because when you have
a topic that you're interested in or a
movement that you wanna be a part of and
you're taking a stance you're staying
was true good ideas don't avoid
criticism and for especially young
people they have a hard time dealing
with that and these important
discussions that need young people to
take a part in it takes a lot of
commitment and I'm not seeing here
saying that I'm amazing and I'm cool but
here's the thing that's important
through me joining this movement and
this important scientific discussion
here's what happened Facebook changed a
platform they were gonna change how they
approached anti-vice content Amazon even
removed misinformed books about autism
in vaccines and then recently GoFundMe
took down anti-tax campaigns we're
talking about movements like this or
causing actual change actually impacting
the way this game is played and the
misinformation that's lying to people
and convincing them of very dangerous
ideas now before I leave because I only
have a short amount of time I want to
give you guys one important thing to
keep in mind what important takeaway
from this all what you can do and what I
did what I did wasn't I didn't do
amazing research and studies and take
information and presented to people I
didn't have deep intellectual scientific
debates with people all I did was share
my story and that's enough for most
people that's enough for most people to
understand the anecdotal experiences the
real people behind the data because data
doesn't resonate with people people
resonate with people and you have to
keep in that in mind because when you
are talking about a topic and you're
sharing your story and sharing what is
important you stay authentic see
authentic to the data to the information
to the importance of this topic if I was
talking to individual and they said why
are vaccines important I would say
nothing alongside any other answer I
would I would not in any way fathom lis
give them an answer outside of people
are dying and that's important and that
children are dying and that's important
and that we're having disease outbreaks
that should not be here and I believe
it's John Boyle put these diseases
should be in history books and not in
our communities so because of that you
need to make a personal decision also to
stand up for truth you need to make a
personal decision for yourself to say
this is accurate this is what's real and
these lies are not okay because it
started with me doing that on a personal
level I wasn't coming from small town to
Senate in a day it wasn't like I go to
bed and I wake up and there's senator
Isakson he's asking questions about
vaccines it was a slow progression and
it started with me saying this is true
my mom doesn't believe it but that's
okay
because that doesn't change the truth it
doesn't change what's accurate and
what's important and honestly the
biggest thing this whole idea of
unbreakable remain unbroken when you
stand there for what's true when you
have that criticism and you're trying to
cause a movement don't sway thank you
[Applause]